Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to Mr. Massagy!
Hey Johnny ya' great bastard!
It's your old mate Oliver here!
Listen... the night is young and so are we.
OH I've been *kisses muscles*
LOADIN' MY MAN GUNS!
HAIIIHHH! *pop* *deflates*
What's my profile...
There's a sexy guy in my photo!
*laughter* Oh wait it's just me!
Well that sounds like me! :)
WOOH! I've got a match!
*female voice* Hi Johnny, I'm soo glad you made it
This means a lot to me..
*Freaked out Markimoo* AHHHH!
*More freaking out Markimoo* AHHHHHHHH!
You know what, that's literally racist buddy..
Yeah, I am a werewolf!
OH MY GOSH!
So once I dated that stable boy
And he had a pet duck
And emphasis on HAD...
I Just couldn't resist that delicious looking duck!
I'm gonna make a duck sound!
*Really squeaky duck sound noise thing*
*Growling sounds*
OH FU- OH FUCKING FUCK
HOLY SHIT!
You've been nothing but charming and understanding
and only slightly racist tonight!
So you know what?!
*seductively* I want you to be the first guy welcomed into my cave... ;)
IS THAT A EUPHEMISM?
AH!
I don't like WHAT'S GOING ON HERE!
AND A FUCKING WEREWOLF!
I'M NOT A DUCK!
Oh that's- oh boy
That's nice :)
Oh that-
*Surprised/what/confused Markimoo noises*
Okay that's fine...
*GETTING THE FUCK OUTTA THERE MARKIMOO* AAAAAAAHHHHHHHH!
*Nice music :)*